[music]
>> Basically, the major difference is in
retention.
Today's research tells us
that when you read something
an average human being what he reads, he
retains 10% of what he has read. Average
human being.
What a person hears
what he hears an average human being, he
retains 20% of what he has heard.
What a person sees
an average human being retains 30% of
what he has seen.
What a person hears and sees together,
it's called as video. Video is a short
form of
short form of
Everyone knows video?
You know the meaning of video, raise
your hand.
Who knows the meaning of video? Video
you don't know?
How did you pass? The test? Video you
know video?
You don't know?
Not the short form.
You know everyone knows. But do we think
where it's come from? What is the root
word?
It's visual and audio.
V I of visual
and audio A U D I O. So video, it's a
coining of new word. Video means visual
and audio put together.
We are learning Dawah here, but we're
learning many things inshallah.
I've been using this word video for 20
years. I did not know it means visual
and audio. So, if you see and hear
together, video the average human being
retains 50% of what he has seen and
heard together.
Which is better, reading or hearing
or seeing?
Which is better?
Seeing and hearing together, best
amongst these three things.
This is research
not done by Muslims, but non-Muslims.
It's better research. If you read the
Edgar scale again research
and that's the new revision in my notes
that is there.
There's a cone of learning, called a
cone of learning.
Same thing.
What you read after 2 weeks you retain
10%. What you read if someone asks you
after 2 weeks 10% average human being
will retain.
What you hear after 2 weeks you'll
retain 20%. What you see after 2 weeks
you'll retain 30%. What you hear and see
like movies
you'll retain
50%.
He goes a step further and says that
what you say
after 2 weeks you retain 70%.
For example
you have prepared for a speech.
Correct? Everyone prepared for the
3-minute speech?
If you prepare you say it. After 2 weeks
I will be able to repeat it. Average
human being will only be able to repeat
70%.
Some may be able to repeat 100% average.
So, what you say
you retain average 70% for 2 weeks.
But we are not here to teach you for 2
weeks.
You want it to be permanent inshallah.
That is the reason repetition,
rehearsals.
He goes to a level further and says that
if you say and enact
like saying means in a group discussion
maybe in a TV talk saying. But if you
enact it
like you do a skit
you enact it you're saying
see, hearing, all put together, the
chances you'll retain after 2 weeks is
90%.
If you enact it enact you know the
people normally have to
do a skit in schools you enact a skit.
I'm talking about halal inshallah.
If you ask them to enact after 2 weeks
average human being will be able to
repeat it
90%. 2 weeks. It doesn't give the scale
after 2 weeks.
From here we come to know that we use
those media in which it will retain in
your customers more.
If you don't know what is what many
people do Dawah is effective not knowing
what is the pros and cons.
So, you as a Daii knows technically what
is pros and cons, the Dawah effect is
much more.
Now I'm distributing books, huh? He
doesn't know what is the difference
between book and
I'm doing for sake of Allah,
alhamdulillah. You'll get your reward.
But if you are more effective you'll get
more reward.
Chances of getting more reward is more.
Main is near, main is Allah's help
hard work
and technique.
This is what I'm talking about is
technique.
Allah's help you have to ask Allah
directly.
Hard work is your hard work.
Third is technique.
So, each one has its pros and cons.
Each media has its own specialty.
Pros and cons.
How to do writing?
You know, we have an organization script
writers.
Script writer means their specialty is
writing script. If you ask them to speak
out of 100 they may not get 10 also.
In writing they're very good.
Some people are good in both.
They are script writers. That's a
technique.
In media there's specialization of
journalism which is a different ball
game altogether.
So, in media when you go there's
specialty of journalism, there's
specialty of editing there's specialty
of cameraman, the direction
everything is a specialty.
So, this in short
was talking about the media and its
effectiveness. Talking about indirect
media
which we shall touch inshallah
on out of four we'll touch a little bit
on the audio
video and social media to a greater
extent inshallah.
Due to limitation of time, one day
for social media is not sufficient.
One day for satellite media is not
sufficient.
In satellite social media alhamdulillah
we have 250 people employed full-time
only for satellite and social media.
Full-time paid employees we have got.
Only for we'll discuss that later on.
It's a specialty by itself.
We speak for a little bit time
on the topic of Dawah without a media,
live and direct in which this
main training program is for.
Dawah
when done live and direct
without a media it may include a media.
Like what I'm doing now is direct Dawah,
but I have a media in between. Audio
media.
Without this
I may have to strain my voice, I may
have to call you closer and
So, though it's a live and direct
media the advantage in live Dawah and
indirect Dawah is the live Dawah
is more often a dialogue.
You can question.
An indirect Dawah, the chances of
questioning wasn't there earlier, but
now it is being included. I told you
technology is making it everything all
the negative factors to be removed. But
previously when media came there was no
radio or new year you can't ask.
Television you can hear and see.
So, in indirect media and mainly it is a
monologue one way. In a direct media
mainly it is a dialogue.
You're doing Dawah with a person you're
telling something, he's questioning you.
He can agree with you, he can disagree,
so it's a dialogue. More effective?
Monologue is less effective but the
reach of the monologue is more.
When I'm doing Dawah through the radio
station million people, satellite
hundreds of million.
Direct one-to-one
or two people or FIVE PEOPLE OR 10
PEOPLE, how many? 20.
Now because of public address system
I'm addressing 20 here, but I can
address 200,000.
The largest gathering I've addressed is
1 million people live.
It's alhamdulillah the largest gathering
in the world for any religious speaker,
not a conference. Alhamdulillah in India
in Bihar.
That's in Kishanganj 2012. More than a
million people live not satellite.
The public address system we had we had
many screens.
So, we can increase
the quantity by including
in it a media. So, it's Dawah live
at the same time including some
media.
These are the main advantages and
disadvantages between direct and
indirect, but
the indirect media also can be converted
into a dialogue like having on a radio
broadcast station question and answer
session. I've been to many countries in
Europe, in South Africa, in America. I'm
having a session asking questions.
In the late '90s.
Now you have even question and answer
session on television which was not
there earlier.
Previously
the peace conference we did we had to
hire a satellite. The first conference.
Without satellite
how can you see live? Now you can have
on the Wi-Fi.
On the internet
a broadband
easier.
Previously live telecasting permission
from the government downlinking
permission. Now no permission, direct.
Now if I want to have this live, it's
easy for me. I can show it live also.
I don't want to show it, but I can.
So, the technology is improving and the
disadvantages are being reduced.
So, the monologue can be converted into
a dialogue in the media also. Each has
its pros and cons.
Now, coming to the basic life dawah,
basic life dawah, direct dawah, it can
either be done on individual level
or it can be done on a public level.
This training program is mainly
specialty
of doing dawah on a public level.
But, when we say we are training you for
a public level, we are killing two birds
with one stone.
When I train you for an individual
dawah, you cannot come on the stage
generally.
But, when I'm training you for the
public level,
most of it can be used on individual
level also.
So, what you're doing on the public
stage,
if you do on individual level, if not
100%, you'll be successful more than
80%.
Because we're training you for question
answer also.
But, if you're trained as an individual
dawah, so a person who's a specialist in
one-to-one, chances of him being
also a specialist of stage is rare. If
you have not gone on stage, okay, you're
very good in talking one-to-one. Okay,
now go on the stage. He may come and get
cold feet.
But, a person who's speaking on the
stage, if you ask him to speak
one-to-one, if not the same effectively,
at least be 80% effective. So,
therefore, we are teaching you something
which is a higher standard, it
indirectly includes the lower also.
So, therefore, we'll not spend much time
on individual dawah one-to-one. I'll
just give you a few examples which will
be sufficient.
In one-to-one dawah,
you can do to a person
who's known to you or unknown to you.
There are a few tips you should remember
in one-to-one dawah. Public dawah has
many requirements which we'll deal in
detail, inshallah, over these 33 days.
But, what's used in public dawah, most
of it, if not all, can be used on
one-to-one. But, there are certain
techniques in one-to-one dawah which, if
you don't know,
because in one-to-one dawah, you may do
with a stranger or with a
known person. Stranger means you're
traveling in a bus
or in a train.
You know that the person sitting next to
you is unknown to you.
Maybe you are with him for 10 to 20
minutes.
Now, how to do dawah with him in 10 to
20 minutes is a different technique.
You're traveling in a plane. You know
your flight is for 5 hours or for 6
hours.
You know he's going to be with you.
He cannot run away, correct?
Now, how to do dawah
with a stranger non-Muslim who's sitting
next to you for 5 hours
is a different technique.
Unknown.
If you don't do dawah,
you may never meet him again in your
lifetime.
Imagine the co-passenger in the bus or
the train
or in the plane.
Bus may be 20 minute journey, train may
be 3 hours, plane may be 5 hours. If you
don't do dawah to him,
the chance you will meet him again in
your life is negligible.
Unknown person, huh?
Unknown. Known person, you're traveling
with your friend, you may travel with
them again also. Therefore, I'm
categorizing into dawah to known people,
dawah to unknown people. He's an unknown
stranger. Imagine you missed the
opportunity. You may never meet him in
your life.
So, things which are rarely acquired, if
you miss that,
you may never get that opportunity
again.
>> [music]
[music]